his unpopularity dominated the
australian election campaign and cost
the liberal national party the election
less than three months after scott
morrison resigned as party leader he's
now under pressure to resign from
parliament after he confirmed that he
secretly appointed himself to five
additional ministerial roles during the
pandemic
i believed it was necessary to have
authority
to have what were effectively emergency
powers
to exercise in extreme situations that
would be unforeseen
that would enable me to act in the
national interest
and that is what i did in a crisis
morrison swore himself in as a joint
health minister finance resources home
affairs as well as treasurer between
2020 and 2021. he didn't reveal these
additional portfolios to the public
parliament nor to most of his colleagues
that's raised questions with the current
government which is seeking advice from
the country's solicitor general the
australian people went to an election
not knowing that any of this had
occurred not knowing that there was a
shadow government operating in darkness
without transparency a clear misleading
of the parliament whereby
parliamentarians and ministers are held
to account
for areas in which they have
responsibility
morrison says his actions didn't impact
anyone but it gave the former prime
minister additional powers which he used
to overrule the resources minister on an
unpopular gas drilling permit before the
election
legal analysts say the governor
general's role overseeing the
appointments and the lack of
transparency involved warrant an
investigation
so this is fundamentally inconsistent
with the basic conventions of our
westminster system
the government the ministers are
accountable to parliament and misleading
parliament as to who exercises
ministerial power is completely at odds
with those conventions
so this is extremely unorthodox it is a
breach of constitutional convention
the former prime minister may have
apologized to his colleagues but that
hasn't quelled calls from within his
party for him to resign from parliament
that's a step so far that scott morrison
is refusing to take sarah clark al
jazeera brisbane australia